les consciences et fait de tels
scandales de tels drames de telles
tragédies dans la vie oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 11 janvier
pour le moment les chiffres à date nous
laisse penser que le couvre-feu suffit
précise jean castex mais ajoute un
troisième confinement n'est pas à
exclure en dernier recours la france qui
marche donc sur un fil et scrute
l'évolution de l'épidémie alors que la
menace du variant britannique se fait de
plus en plus sentir avec au moins huit
cas à marseille et deux cas à lille
plus de cinquante mille doses du vaccin
moderne a livré aujourd'hui afin d'être
utilisé dans la semaine les démocrates
viennent de déposer à la chambre des
représentants aux états unis un acte
d'accusation contre donald trump
première étape vers l'ouverture formelle
d'une deuxième procédure de destitution
contre le président sortant qu'ils
accusent d'avoir incité à la violence au
capitole donald trump banni
définitivement de twitter guélat merkel
et d'autres d'ailleurs juge
problématique cette suspension
[Musique]
on
sur le front du coc vite c'est une
semaine décisive qui s'annonce avec deux
points qui seront particulièrement
scrutées par le gouvernement les
éventuelles conséquences du réveillon du
nouvel an et celle du variant anglais
est détectée sur le territoire en
attendant les réunions s'enchaînent avec
la question épineuse d'un troisième
confinement pour le moment exclue
les explications de neige à dera sach il
ne faut pas exclure un troisième
confinement dernier recours les propos
sont signés du premier ministre alors
que nos voisins britanniques et
allemands ont déjà reconfirmer depuis
plusieurs semaines jean castex à
envisager d'y avoir recours pour
l'hexagone
une troisième fois ce matin lors d'une
réunion avec les parlementaires et la
mise en oeuvre ne pourrait être qu'une
question de temps on parle également
d'une éventuelle mise en place d'un
couvre-feu à 18h étendue à tout le
territoire et pour cause les chiffres
liés aux comics 19 continue d'alarmé le
nombre de cas de contamination quotidien
tourne autour de 20 milles ces derniers
jours
situation d'autant plus inquiétante que
le variant britannique a été détectée
sur le territoire français à bagneux
lille marseille invariants dont on dit
qu'il est plus contagieux sous le feu
des critiques après un début de campagne
de vaccination timide
emmanuel macron a piloté ce lundi après
midi une réunion de crise consacrée à la
stratégie de vaccination le chef de
l'état il était accompagné des
principaux ministres concernés
d'ailleurs il faut savoir que les
premières doses du vaccin moderna
doivent être livrés à partir de ce lundi
pour renforcer la capacité vaccinale
dans les zones les plus touchées par
l'épidémie
mercredi un nouveau conseil de défense
est prévue à l'elysée juste avant le
conseil des ministres
et parmi les sujets à l'ordre du jour il
sera probablement question de mesures
plus restrictives pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus
les conséquences des mouvements des
fêtes de fin d'année
devraient aussi être connu et puis
seront sûrement aborder les inquiétudes
liées aux variantes anglaise et sud
africaines du virus inquiétudes qui
pourrait donc précipité des décisions
sur des mesures encore plus restrictive
troisième confinement couvre feu dès 18h
étendues à tout le pays ce sera donc à
jean castex et olivier ferrandes annoncé
d'éventuelles nouvelles mesures le
lendemain jeudi pour la traditionnelle
conférence de presse hebdomadaire et
peut-être même une prise de parole du
président de la république
emmanuel macron une semaine qui
s'annonce donc chargée est crucial pour
le gouvernement
et si un recond finement et donc écartée
au niveau national pour le moment à
marseille la première adjointe
écologiste l'ancien maire michel rubio
rôle à elle le réclame une éventualité
écartée là aussi pour le moment par la
mairie le département des bouches du
rhône est entré en couvre-feu avancé à
18 heures hier soir tout comme sept
autres départements dans la cité
phocéenne les marins pompiers sont
mobilisés pour traquer la variante
anglaise du coc vide détecté sur huit
personnes une surveillance via les eaux
usées a été mise en place notamment et
pour parler de la situation à marseille
nous sommes avec stéphane ravier
sénateurs rnd bouche le rhône président
du groupe rassemblement national au
conseil municipal de marseille c'est
notre rubrique l'invité ce soir
bonsoir stéphane ravier merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
marseille
autrefois présenté comme le bon élève
est désormais dans le viseur à les
autorités maires et préfets confondues
constate une évolution je suis
défavorable est très rapide dans le
département des bouches du rhône une
réaction
oui on parle beaucoup plus de marseille
quand elle serait le soi disant mauvais
élèves que lorsqu'elle était bonne élève
il ya quelques mois alors que l'épidémie
était jaillir juguler à marseille parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de tests réalisés
en amont par un certain professeur raout
et qui proposait un un traitement qui
n'était pas le sien il n'avait
absolument aucun dividende a touché dans
sept à obtenir dans le dans
l'utilisation de ceux de ce traitement
est bien marseille on a un petit peu mis
de côté on a même vilipendé notre notre
druide à nous notre notre professeur out
alors aujourd'hui on s'acharne sur
marseille mais je constate qu'un 48
heures la valeur variant britannique a
déjà fait mille kilomètres puisqu'on le
trouve désormais à lille alors marseille
n'est pas plus mauvais élèves que les
autres les marseillais ont appliqué les
consignes sanitaires que le gouvernement
nous a infligé avec les résultats que
l'on connaît voilà les les mesures
coercitives voire liberticide imposée
par le gouvernement manifestement ne
savent ne servent à rien il a tellement
pris de retard dans tous les domaines
depuis le mois de mars l'année dernière
que eh bien c'est la fuite en avant dans
les mesures liberticides qui nous impose
il y avait le couvre feu à 22 heures
puis de couvre-feu à 20 heures du couvre
feu désormais à 18h pour marseille pour
l'ensemble des bouches du rhône sens que
vraiment cela n'améliore la situation
s'est donc les mesures de restriction
des libertés ne sont manifestement pas
les bonnes et pourtant stéphane ravier
la france ce n'est pas la plus
contrainte pour le moment vous le savez
il ya qu'à voir nos voisins justement
anglais
qui sont reconfirmer de recombiner
totalement michel rubio l'art votre
ancien maire à marseille propose
d'ailleurs de recombiner la ville canton
c'est vous c'est trop selon vous c'est
excessif ou trop tard la même rue biot
madame ruby or là ce n'était pas un
maire c'était un éphémère merde pendant
pendant quelques semaines ou quelques
mois durant lesquels on ne l'avons pas
entendu aujourd'hui elle ne cesse de
s'exprimer avec un positionnement qui va
à l'encontre de celui qui l'a remplacé
justement au poste de premier adjoint ne
sont déjà plus d'accord entre eux
toujours plus de rectrice de
restrictions toujours plus de
contraintes
vous parliez du de l'exemple britannique
alors si les britanniques sont victimes
je dirais de mesures plus restrictives
qu'en france parce contre le l'objectif
du gouvernement britannique en matière
de vaccination puisque ça nous et ça
nous est présenté comme étant l' arme
absolue moi personnellement je ne me
ferai pas vacciner
le rassemblement national laisse le
libre choix aux français en tout cas
c'est notre ligne
moi je ne me ferai pas vacciner mais je
pense quand même à celles et ceux qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner je ne les
blâme ni je les soutiens c'est leur
choix et bien en grande bretagne
l'objectif c'est de ces de vacciner 15
millions des sujets de sa majesté en
france et un million un million alors si
les britanniques sont que sont confinés
ils ont quand même l'espoir dans
quelques semaines est bien de sortir de
cette crise sanitaire ce qui n'est pas
du tout le cas en france
nous cumulons des mois et des mois de
restriction de nos libertés et qui met
en danger notre économie tout ça devient
vraiment insupportable mais tout de même
stéphane ravier
il ya ce variant un britannique huit cas
détectés à marseille et pas seulement
vous l'avais dit à lille et sans doute
bientôt ailleurs ça ne vous inquiète pas
plus que cela parce que vous dites voilà
à trop de restrictions en même temps le
vaccin vous n'y croyez pas alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour lutter contre ce
virus selon vous non moi je ne dis pas
que je ne crois pas aux banques sur mon
jeu du concert
avec ciné vous aussi tous les français
pensent comme vous il ya personne qui se
fait vacciner il n'y a pas d'immunité on
se confine pas non plus donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait moi j'ai moi moi moi je
laisse les mois je pense que les
français sont des adultes qui sont doués
de réflexion et c'est à eux se faire un
avis et apparaît à partir de là à
décider si oui ou non la vaccination est
le meilleur moyen pour lutter contre
cette épidémie on nous dit que oui et on
n'y met pas les moyens
encore une fois à marseille nous sommes
le 11 janvier bien le 8 janvier oui
c'est à 72 heures pour une ville de huit
cent soixante dix mille habitants
nous ne disposions que de cinq mille
doses de vaccin alors si elle est là la
réalité c'est parce que le gouvernement
a pris tellement de retard dans ce qu'il
a lui-même présenté comme étant le
larmes absolue contre contre cette
épidémie
donc il a tellement pris de retard qu'il
est contrainte par son incompétence par
son impréparation à a confiné à
incarcérer les marseillais et les
habitants des bouches du rhône en
général et puis d'autres départements
aujourd'hui c'est ça la réalité alors
vous l'avez dit l'exécutif qui table sur
un million de vaccinés d'ici à la fin du
mois notamment grâce à l'arrivée du
vaccin modern ans dont les 50 mille
premières doses sont acheminées dans le
grand test on le voit sur ces images
mais aussi en rhône alpes pas bon
auvergne et rhône-alpes et en paca chez
vous
ce vaccin d'ailleurs qui va se conserver
plus facilement parce qu'il a besoin
d'être conservée à moins 20 degrés
contre moins 70 pour fiber vous êtes
très méfiant contrairement d'ailleurs au
maire de marseille à benoît paillard qui
dit il faut se faire vacciner au au plus
vite vous vous garder une certaine
réserve donc stéphane ravier on l'aura
compris alors je le dis c'est tout à
fait personnel c'est un choix personnel
ça n'engage que moi mais c'est dans tous
les sens du terme
je n'incite personne à faire comme moi
je n'incite personne à choisir le vaccin
je laisse je laisse la liberté de choix
à mes compatriotes
marcy et français en général qui doivent
se faire un avis sur la pertinence de ce
vaccin
personnellement j'estime ne pas avoir
assez de retour sur les conséquences de
cette vaccination
prononcer le retour c'est pas le fait de
voilà de se faire vacciner dans l'absolu
c'est pour l'instant c'est trop tôt pour
vous vous n'avez pas eu assez de recul
notamment de la part des études
scientifiques
moi je crois avoir je n'ai pas vérifié
mon mais mon carnet de vaccinations à
jour je ne suis pas un militant anti
vaccins ce que je constate là c'est
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de zones
d'ombré d'incertitude j'ai pu participer
chez sur un plateau de l'onu au vos
confrères de télévision un débat il y à
une quinzaine de jours où il y avait
deux spécialistes une été ré était une
députée de la république en marche et
puis une autre médecin qui ont confronté
leurs points de vue sur cette
vaccination et sur ses conséquences
éventuelles et j'ai entendu le on ne
sait pas on verra
c'est un pari nous ne savons qu'au repas
finalement ce qui peut se passer ensuite
moi dans le tout dans le doute je
m'abstiens merci beaucoup en tout cas
stéphane ravier sénateurs est reine des
bouches du rhône président du groupe
rassemblement national dont conseil
municipal de marseille merci d'avoir été
avec nous pas de confinement donc pour
l'instant à marseille ni ailleurs en
france d'ailleurs mais le mot semble
être sur toutes les lèvres alors on le
craignent ou qu'on le souhaite faute il
anticipé est confiné la population pour
la troisième fois dans notre pays
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec frédéric
à la postolle professeur de médecine
d'urgence au samu 93 bonsoir frédéric
lapostolle merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés michel parigot président de
l'association corona victime chercheur
au cnrs bonsoir à vous aussi alors on le
disait à l'instant inquiétude à lille et
à marseille où plusieurs cas de ce
fameux variant britanniques ont été
repérés dans la cité phocéenne il ya des
élus et bien qu'ils proposent même un ro
confinement est ce qu'il devient
inévitable vu la vitesse à laquelle
l'épidémie se propage en france michel
parigot
il sera inévitable le problème c'est que
de toute façon la stratégie qu'on a pris
est pas la bonne
il faudrait une stratégie d'éradication
du virus elle qu'on a pris dans un
certain nombre de pays du sud est
asiatique et qui marche et on sait
comment comment il faut faire et là on
se cale uniquement sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations et la limite des
hôpitaux
donc en fait le fait de pas confiné
maintenant fait qu'on va avoir une
explosion et que même on va dépasser la
limite des hôpitaux très très rapidement
parce que à partir du moment où on n'a
pas au moment où on a su qu'il y avait
le variant engrais et on la suit
finalement rapidement parce que les
anglais soient sont bien meilleurs que
nous pour pour tester et donc à si on
avait à ce moment là a pris la décision
de confiner on aurait pu éviter cette
explosion maintenant on va la voir
l'explosion et donc on va re confiné
mais on va re confiné dans une situation
qui sera encore plus mauvaise qu'elle
est maintenant c'est à dire que
maintenant on est déjà entre 300 et 400
morts par un parent jouer on pense que
ça suffit pas il faut encore aller plus
loin et en gros la limite c'est ses 800
morts par jour parce que là les hôpitaux
tiennent plus et là on prend des
décisions
enfin je trouve que c'est une stratégie
qui est absurde frédéric lapostolle vous
partagez cet avis de confinement c'est
en gros la seule chose qui marche faute
de bonnes stratégies à en croire michel
parigot pourtant les
résultat du deuxième ont été assez
mitigés la preuve avec notre discussion
parce qu'il a été arrêté
globalement je crois qu'il ya au niveau
national et international plus de
discussions sur le sujet quand on confie
on relâche la pression sur le système
hospitalier canton déconfite même si on
fait par étapes
on remet la pression sur le système
hospitalier et les effets du confinement
du déconfinement se mesure à distance à
dire 3 4 semaines après et ça peut aussi
tuer tuer en fonction des événements
évidemment un rassemblement familial
un événement quelconque donc il n'ya
plus de doute aujourd'hui que le
traitement de référence et là je
m'inscris complètement infos sur ce que
disait votre invité politique
précédemment évidemment on n'a pas
d'autre stratégie parce que c'est bien
beau de dire on veut pas confiné on veut
pas vacciner mais on fait comment pour
s'en sortir s'il n'y ont confiné on
vaccine aujourd'hui dans l'attende d'une
campagne de vaccination qui soit
efficace
on n'a pas d'autre remède alors la
question c'est simplement la montée du
niveau de 1 soit en conflit une quand
loi là soit on confine canteloup est là
soit on confine quand elle est là soit
on confine quand elle est là c'est là
que moi en tant que professionnels de
santé évidemment je serais assez
favorable à un confinement le plus
précoce possible le plus drastique
possible maintenant il ne m'appartient
pas de décider et c'est là toute la
problématique à laquelle est confrontée
actuellement la classe politique c'est
de prendre une décision dans laquelle
évidemment il faut mettre en tête de
gondole les conséquences sanitaires
c'est d'évoquer les patients
hospitalisés les décès mais aussi les
conséquences scolaires des conséquences
psychologiques les conséquences sociales
les conséquences économiques et j'en
passe et des meilleurs d'un confinement
donc d'un point de vue sanitaire la
réponse est claire oui plus on confine
plus on maîtrise l'épidémie mais la
décision doit intégrer d'autres éléments
et ça il appartient aux politiques d'en
juger
et manifestement jean castex ne s'est
pas laissé tenter par cette ce par cette
solution radicale pour le moment il dit
que le couvre-feu suffit que les
chiffres voilà exclut pour l'instant un
troisième confinement michel parigot ça
vous inspire quoi le premier ministre
la phase d'une certaine manière pour
préserver comme le dit votre collègue
l'économie le scolaire le psychologique
sauf qu on a les deux c'est à dire on n'
économique est détruite
et puis on a les morts encore une fois
il y avait une autre stratégie qui est
d'éradiquer parce qu'une fois qu'on est
disons en dessous de 1000 contamination
par jour on peut contrôler par un
certain nombre de mesures et en
particulier l'isolément le tester et
retracer les contacts et isolées c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut faire de façon
efficace si on a peu de contamination
quand on a vingt mille ou trente mille
contamination on est strictement
incapable de le faire et donc c'est là
où ça explose alors qu'avec un niveau
très bas
on peut contrôler avec ça avec un usage
un peu pur qu'à des recommandations un
peu plus strictes sur le masque que
celles qui sont faites à l'heure
actuelle et notamment dans le cadre
privé puisque on sait quand même que une
grande partie des contaminations c'est
le cadre privé on peut arriver à
maîtriser
on pourrait arriver à maîtriser cette
épidémie sauf qu'on ne prend pas cette
mesure là et donc on est à partie le
mans on est à des niveaux de
contamination à à vingt ou trente mille
contamination par jour là on ne contrôle
plus rien du tout on t'aimait ces
[ __ ] m et là on va avoir en plus le
paria anglais c'est à dire 50 % de plus
de 2 de contamination et ça c'est énorme
quand on prend parce qu on est sur des
développements qui sont exponentielles
et une exponentielle
quand vous faites une variation de 50pts
de 2 50% c'est dire si vous étiez à 1 ça
s'arrête et quand vous passez à 1,5 vous
exploser donc on est devant quelque
chose où on aura nécessairement
l'explosion et donc on aura
nécessairement le confinement mais à un
moment où on aura les morts le
confinement et le désastre économique
je trouve que c'est drôlement pas la
bonne solution de feu frédéric apostol
tout à l'heure on parlait de ce deuxième
confinement qui n'a pas fonctionné on
entendait michel parigot naudières oui
mais bon il a été arrêté
trop tôt il ya de ça ou alors il n'a pas
été assez drastiques c'est vrai qu'on a
vu les français
vivre en tout cas moi ce que j'en ai vu
à paris sur le périphérique assez
normalement il y avait beaucoup de monde
dans la rue c'était pas assez drastiques
assez sévère ce de ce deuxième
confinement est peut-être trop court
écoutez vous aurez compris que
globalement nous nous rejoignons sur le
constat d'un point de vue médical d'un
point de vue sanitaire il ya assez peu
de discussions plus on confine et plus
on confine de façon stricte plus on va
maîtriser complètement cette épidémie
après les les variables sont celles qui
sont décidés pour d'autres raisons et je
suis entièrement d'accord avec tout ce
qui a été dit un de la même façon que
dans la campagne de vaccination chaque
fois qu'on prend un jour de retard ça
paraît anodin parce que c'est une
journée de retard mais cette journée de
retard c'est des dizaines de milliers de
contamination c'est la propagation du du
variant anglais qui risque de nous
mettre dans une situation qui va
malheureusement se rapprocher de celle
que vivent actuellement les britanniques
donc il ya un certain nombre de facteurs
qui sont cumulés maintenant qui font
qu'on est on peut légitimement être être
inquiet et se dire que la question pour
moi n'est pas de savoir si on si le
conflit car à la question pour moi est
de savoir quand et avec quelle est le
niveau ii d'exigence avec comme
référence ce qui s'est passé au mois de
mars est ce qu'on sera aussi strict
qu'on l'a été au mois de mars est ce que
on va se contenter de couvre feu je
pense que la question aujourd'hui est
d'ailleurs c'est un peu le
positionnement des politiques autour de
ça n'est que dans l'ajustement mais il
ne fait pas de doute quand on voit ce
qui se passe au niveau international
qu'on va aller vers une restriction
encore de ces mesures qui ne vise qu'à
réduire les interactions sociales qui
sont le mode de transmission de ce virus
et donc si on vous le contrôler c'est
par le contrôle des interactions
sociales c'est aussi bête que ça
dans la tente d'avoir suffisamment de la
population qui soit maximum
c'est évidemment le professeur de
médecine qui parle vous vous l'avez dit
vous l'avez nuancer les politiques
le vois pas de la même l'entendent pas
les mêmes oreilles ils ne le voient pas
du même oeil à droite comme à gauche on
propose d'écouter jean pierre raffarin
et jean luc mélenchon un troisième
confinement appauvrirait
considérablement et peut-être
irrémédiablement la france donc il faut
éviter à tout prix ce troisième
confinement c'est ça la stratégie et je
crois qu'il faut y contribuer on ne
pourra pas faire vivre la france en
confinement déconfinement re confinement
tous les 3 mois pendant un an et demi qu
2 il faut préparer des alternatives au
confinement
il faut penser plus loin que le bout de
son nez jean pierre raffarin s'est il
faut éviter à tout prix 1
on dirait presque quoi qu'il en coûte
mais il ne l'a pas dit quant à jean luc
mélenchon et bien il faut que et écouter
éviter pardon le stop and go
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces deux
politiques qui nous disent ça
eric lapostolle vous voyez bien qu'on
tourne un peu autour du pot c'est ce que
je vous disais précédemment
on emploiera probablement les politiques
seront assez forts pour ça on n'emploie
pas le mot mais on va si besoin se
rapprocher de mesures de restriction qui
ressembleront bigrement au confinement
est effectivement le risque si on veut
éviter le terme et la liste de ces
mesures c'est que ce soit des mesures
qui soient prises un peu un peu
tardivement michel parigot vous vous
devriez prendre une décision et
conseiller le gouvernement
quelle sorte de confinement vous leur
préconiserez aujourd'hui je pense que le
confinement qui avait lieu au mois de
novembre enfin jusqu'au 28 novembre
puisque là ça a été l'ouverture générale
était efficace on avait un confinement
on était tombé à erquy et et 0,6 à hervé
rose 0,6 on diminue très très rapidement
si on avait continué à trois semaines
pendant trois semaines ce régime là on
pouvait arriver en dessous de 2000
contaminations par rapports à par jour
et là on pouvait maîtriser sans
confinement c'est ça qui était terrible
de devoir c'est que ya des possibilités
de maîtriser sans confinement mais il
faut d'abord confiné descendre le nombre
de contaminations à un niveau où on
puisse maîtriser par d'autres moyens
et c'est ça qu'on ne qu'on ne fait pas
donc là on va aller de demi mesure en
demi mesure c'est à dire on va on veut
pas parler de confinement donc on va y
aller progressivement
ce qui veut dire qu'on va augmenter tout
simplement le nombre de contaminations
et le nombre de décès jusqu'au moment où
on peut plus faire autrement que de que
de que de confiner et essai et mais on
aura quand même confiné à la fin donc on
aura tous les inconvénients en même
temps merci en tout cas à tous les deux
frédéric lapostolle et michel parigot
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et on en vient à cet appel de
l'om est ce vendredi dernier
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
demandent l'arrêt des accords bilatéraux
entre état et laboratoire elle plaide en
faveur d'un accès équitable au vaccin
pour tous les pays
objectif éviter une vaccination à deux
vitesses le point avec hélène masquelier
pour plus de solidarité dans la
distribution des vaccins
l' oms et l'alliance pour les vaccins
ont mis en place le kovacs un mécanisme
permettant d'acquérir des doses pour les
redistribuer aux pays les plus pauvres
alors que la compétition fait rage pour
obtenir des vaccins les plus riches sont
ceux qui s'en sortent le mieux
à eux seuls ils ont préempté la moitié
des 8 milliards de doses prévues les
pays à plus faible revenu soit les
quatre cinquièmes de la population
doivent eux se partagent et l'autre
moitié une disparité vivement critiqué
par le ms exhorte les pays et les
fabricants à cesser de conclure des
accords bilatéraux au détriment du
kovacs aucun pays n'est exceptionnelle
et deux doigts resquiller et vacciner
toute la population alors que certains
restent sans approvisionnement en
vaccins
cet appel intervient alors que l'union
européenne a doublé cette semaine ses
précommandes du vaccin
eiser biotech lieu qui avec les
etats-unis le canada le royaume uni et
l'inde fait partie de ceux qui ont
acheté le plus de doses des accords tous
azimuts qui ont eu pour conséquence de
faire grimper les prix rendant le vaccin
encore plus inaccessible aux pays
pauvres
le kovacs permettraient de mutualiser
les achats de doses et de les
redistribuer dans l'unique cadre de ce
mécanisme
faisant ainsi du vaccin un bien public
mondial
brax hymne national or le nationalisme
vaccinale nous fait du mal à tous et est
voué à l'échec
mais d'un autre côté la vaccination
équitable sauvent des vies stabilise des
systèmes de santé et conduirait à une
véritable reprise économique mondiale
qui stimulerait la création d'emplois
vacciner équitablement les populations
pour lutter contre le virus sans
aggraver les inégalités c'est là l'autre
défi de cette pandémie reste avec nous
dans quelques instants nous en viendrons
à sur les démocrates américains qui
souhaitent utiliser de 25e amendement de
la constitution américaine pour des
tu es donald trump avant le 20 janvier
et puis nous évoquons la politique que
souhaite mettre en place joe biden à
l'égard de la chine en formant une
grande alliance démocratique
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les lames on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
n'a rien changé par exemple par rapport
à son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez encore
neuf jours de mandature pour donald
trump avant l'investiture de joe biden
mais son séjour à la maison blanche
pourrait peut-être raccourcie les
démocrates viennent de présenter l'acte
d'accusation et déposa l'instant une
résolution demandant vice président mike
pence de démettre de ses fonctions au
président au républicain sortant walid
bennani un parking quelques voitures
mais des panneaux bien visible au slogan
choc traître et une pige traduisez
accusé en référence à l' empêchement est
le 25e amendement de la constitution
américaine
après l'envahissement d'un des symboles
de la démocratie à washington par les
supporters de donald trump mercredi les
démocrates n'ont qu'une idée en tête
chaque jour se débarrasser du 45e
président américain au plus vite
quiconque a perdu le contrôle de ses
capacités mentales à ce niveau jusqu'à
déclencher une insurrection contre les
états unis ne devraient pas avoir le
doigt sur le bouton nucléaire et bien
j'aime le 25e amendement parce que ça
nous débarrasse de lui il n'est plus en
fonction mais il ya un fort soutien au
congrès pour mettre en accusation le
président une seconde fois une deuxième
tentative de destitution rend un an et
demi les démocrates ont déjà d'ailleurs
rédigé l'article de mise en accusation
le parlement américain et ses élus
doivent se prononcer sur cette question
dans les prochaines 48 heures
objectif suprême pour le camp démocrate
interdire donald trump d'exercer de
futures fonctions fédérales
fait notable pour cette deuxième
procédure d'impeachment plusieurs grands
élus républicains approuvent
l'initiative
ces derniers indigné par les images du 6
janvier
émeutes qui ont fait cinq morts et une
quinzaine de personnes ont été inculpées
à ce jour eh bien je pense que la
meilleure façon pour notre pays et que
le président démissionne et s'en aille
le plus tôt possible
je reconnais que ce n'est peut-être pas
probable mais je pense que ce serait la
meilleure solution est la meilleure
chose pour l'unité du pays
ce serait qu'il démissionne une
procédure de destitution qui s'annonce
compliqué juridiquement et presque
irréalisable d'ici le 20 janvier et
l'intronisation du président élu joe
biden
les américains partagés sur la question
on est vraiment proche de la fin de son
administration pour le pays je pense
qu'il serait préférable qu'il part de
son propre chef qu'il démissionne je
crains qu'en forme compte s'il était
destitué ce serait perçu comme une
punition qui détournerait l'attention
dans le mauvais sens
et j'aimerais juste voir bail de monter
au créneau et aller de l'avant
banni des réseaux sociaux twitter
facebook ou encore instagram donald
trump ne compte pas pour autant se
ternir dans le silence jusqu'à son
départ de la maison blanche un
déplacement ce mardi au texas est prévue
avec pour thème l'immigration et la
construction des murs le long de la
frontière avec le mexique
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston avec dave perkins analyse
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous on le voit les américains un petit
peu partagés sur cette tentative de
faire sortir entre guillemets donald
trump avant la fin officielle de son
mandat
c'est important selon vous des missions
ou destitution c'est important pour ses
détracteurs que donald trump ne finisse
pas son mandat de manière classique et
lowell certaine façon cela montre que
les démocrates qui ont du mal à monter
une accusation solide contre donald
trump tous ceux qui l'on sait c'est
moyen vraiment obscur et sans doute
qu'ils n'auront pas assez de temps pour
mener à terme sa procédure
voici trois chose qui pourrait arriver
tout d'abord leurs tentatives échouent
ils devraient échouer mais je pense que
elle avancera un peu car beaucoup des
républicains se sont retournés contre
les lynx 30 du cours de la dernière
semaine
cette tentative pourrait réussir et il
pourrait essayer de mettre en havrais
cette procédure avant l'inauguration il
ne reste plus beaucoup de temps car il
s'agit d'une procédure à deux parties
tout d'abord les articles de lingerie
chemin puis le procès devant le sénat et
ce procès qui pourrait déboucher selon
le souhait des démocrates sur une
décision de culpabilité
donc ils ont commencé à essayer de
lancer une pression sus les donald trump
pourrait en fait arrivé à la fin de son
mandat avant la fin du processus et donc
il n'y aurait plus aucune fondation
aucun fondement légal pour cette
procédure car on ne peut pas
destituer un citoyen à titre civil est
donc une solution serait de le parler
parler parler essayer de décider de la
culpabilité de donald trump et a décidé
que cela le rend inéligible à un avenir
espère qu'une seule d'une certaine
manière ce que vous admettez que les
démocrates ce qu'ils font même s'ils
n'obtiennent pas une destitution de
toute façon c'est la fin du mandat de
donald trump mais c'est assez habile
dans la mesure où ils vont obliger les
républicains à se compter entre eux il y
aura les purs les durs ceux qui vont
soutenir jusqu'au bout donald trump et
qui vont peut-être être accusée d'avoir
d'une certaine manière soutenue ces
événements qui se sont passés au
capitole et les autres qui auront dix
n'ont donc c'est assez complexe qui va
se passer en terme de votes
surendettement du capitole il ne
s'agissait que d'un mois d'une centaine
de personnes sur les milliers de
personnes qui étaient là et je pense que
tout le monde comprend aux états unis
que les démocrates essaye de prétendre
que des événements horribles ont eu lieu
alors que lorsqu'on jette un regard
objectif sur ce qui s'est passé mais
avait que quelques forcené a qui sont
pénétrées il n'a eu quasiment pas de
dégâts et d'ailleurs quand on compare
cela aux manifestations des anti fallout
et blake lively matters ce qui est
arrivé au capitole
ça n'est vraiment pas sérieux mais il
essaye de grossières cela afin de
réduire l'influencé le pouvoir de donald
trump mais je pense que le public aux
états unis comprends tout à fait ce
qu'essaye de faire les démocrate nancy
pelosi essaye de causé assez de dégâts
d'un train pour qu'ils ne puissent pas
être à nouveau candidat et encore mieux
essayer de détruire sa réputation
jusqu'à ce qu'il doive quitter
washington en tant que criminel pour
nuire autant que possible à sa base de
soutien sont contraints oui mais pour
les citoyens qui l'ont suivi vous parlez
évidemment comme comme un défenseur de
donald trump et c'est bien votre droit
et c'est pour ça qu'on vous invite pour
entendre votre voix mais il n'empêche
est ce que ce n'est pas de la trempe lui
même qui s'est tiré une balle dans le
pied avec cette affaire puisqu'il est
quand même vu comme avoir incité à la
violence au capital y compris par de
nombreux républicains n'ont donald trump
n'a pas appelé à la violence capitale
j'ai écouté tout son discours et rien ne
pourrait être interprété de cette façon
s'il n'y a pas ces signaux secret que
les démocrates prétendent entendre de
nha trang utiliser les démocrates
demandent à leurs partisans d'être
hostile envers les républicains
mais donald trump n'a pas tenu ce genre
de discours il n'a pas incité à la
violence et il s'agit encore une fois du
bon sens des électeurs tout ce que les
démocrates font ne va faire que
renforcer la base électorale de donald
trump
il renforce son soutien pour 2024 au fur
et à mesure que
les démocrates essaye de le saboter et
que cela rend les électeurs de plus en
plus furieux
donc je pense que cela va se retourner
contre les démocrates cela montre à quel
point ils ont peur à quel point ils sont
désespérés
merci beaucoup aux devs perkins est
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et on en vient aux relations
commerciales et diplomatiques sino
américaines qui continuent de se tendre
alors que le monde a justement de donald
trump touche à sa fin le secrétaire
d'état américain michael pompéo à lever
les restrictions sur les interactions
entre les représentants américains et
leurs homologues taïwanais ce qui a
provoqué la colère de pékin
quentin mauclair des relations
bilatérales au plus bas alors que
washington a annoncé samedi 9 janvier
l'annulation des restrictions imposées
aux responsables américains dans leurs
interactions avec taiwan pékin montrent
les dents et menace les etats-unis la
chine s'oppose fermement et condamne
vigoureusement l'initiative des états
unis toute action qui porte atteinte aux
intérêts fondamentaux de la chine
recevra une contre attaque résolu de
notre part et ne sera pas couronné de
succès mike pompéo avait mis en avant
des décisions prises je cite
unilatéralement pour satisfaire le
régime communiste de pékin
l'annnonce du chef de la diplomatie
américaine a été reçue d'un bon oeil par
les autorités taïwanaises et le
département d'état américain a déjà
annoncé par l'intermédiaire du
secrétaire d'état monsieur pompéo que
les restrictions concernant les échanges
entre taiwan et les états unis avaient
toutes été levées
il s'agit d'un événement majeur dans le
renforcement des relations entre taiwan
et les états unis
le ministère des affaires étrangères
exprime son accueil chaleureux et sa
gratitude envers une telle décision des
états unis outre ces mesures l'annnonce
de la venue à taipei du 13 au 15 janvier
de l'ambassadrice des etats-unis à l'onu
kelly kraft a été vivement critiquée par
pékin les autorités chinoises menace de
faire payer aux états unis je cite un
lourd tribut si la visite de
l'ambassadrice se déroule comme prévu
taïwan est loin d'être le seul sujet de
tension entre les etats-unis et la chine
depuis ce lundi les américains ne
peuvent investir dans les entreprises
chinoises han
avec des activités militaires la guerre
commerciale entre les deux pays s'est
intensifiée sous donald trump le 45e
président des états unis n'a cessé de
s'attaquer à la chine lors de ses quatre
ans à la maison blanche
en août dernier il avait par exemple
interdit la vente d'équipements
électroniques au géant téléphonique
huawei son successeur joe biden aura la
lourde tâche de prendre la suite du
dossier sino américain le président
américain élu à d'ores et déjà annoncé
sa volonté de créer une alliance
démocratique contre la chine
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
l'odeur blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
bonsoir à claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous mais qu mont péko qui
lève donc les restrictions de contact
avec taiwan un dernier cadeau empoisonné
ou ou pas d'ailleurs de la part de
donald trump wilona de vous ça va
contribuer à dégrader un petit peu plus
les relations entre la chine et les
états unis qui sont déjà prêts mauvaise
mais dont le fond pas tant que cela
parce que ces mesures ne sont pas très
importantes elles ont surtout une valeur
symbolique
et puis en fait au bout du compte cela
va donner des munitions supplémentaires
à l'équipe bayh dole pour la négociation
future qui s'ouvrira avec la chine
alors effectivement le sujet de taille
mal est très sensible et déjà une loi de
2018 dans le fond autoriser les contacts
personnels entre eux les fonctionnaires
américains et les fonctionnaires de
taïwan là on a simplement une mise en
scène supplémentaire par mike pompéo qui
dit je libère complètement les
interdictions et par conséquent les
taiwanais pour revenir librement
discuter avec des interlocuteurs au
state department ou à la maison blanche
et réciproquement à taïwan ceux ci se
faisait plus ou moins déjà dans le passé
et puis pour ce qui est de la visite de
la de l'ambassadrice des etats-unis
auprès de l'onu
bien sûr les chinois ont protesté
vigoureusement
surtout que
elle vient pour prononcer une conférence
qui dira combien taiwan joue un rôle
important dans la communauté
internationale et qu'on a bien tort de
ne pas lui sur une place plus grande
dans les organisations internationales
mais dans le fond au moins d'août
dernier le ministre de la santé
américain est également allé à taipei
pour les féliciter de la manière dont il
gérait la pandémie donc tout ça n'est
pas extrêmement nouveau
ce qui est important par contre parce
que ça c'est substantiel
c'est que pendant sa présidence donald
trump a autorisé 18 milliards de dollars
de ventes d'armes à taiwan et en effet
lorsque les états unis ont changé leur
système de relations avec la chine
lorsqu'ils ont décidé de reconnaître
pékin en 1979 y sont engagés à assurer
la défense de taiwan en tout cas il ya
une loi américaine qui prévoit cela et
donc taiwan joue le rôle d'un irritant
qui permet d'ajuster les négociations en
faites ce que vous voulez monsieur trup
c'était réduire l'excédent commercial
des normes que taïwan a vis-à-vis d'un
certain nombre de pays dont les états
unis et pour ça il a mis les droits de
douanes supplémentaires jusqu'à hauteur
de 70 milliards de dollars
et effectivement c'est cela que les
chinois voudraient voir lever plus ces
sanctions individuelles ou collectives
qui ont été pris lundi vers a dit
fermement par l'administration trup
toute une série de sanctions qui existe
à l'égard de la chine et que évidemment
les chinois aimeraient bien voir lever
d'ailleurs ils sont venus pour négocier
et sur la fée l'aspect et douaniers et
s'était engagé à acheter davantage de
produits agricoles aux états unis ce qui
dans le fond ne s'est pas vraiment un
produit puisque la présidence tram pet
est sur sa fin et les chinois comment
vont-ils aborder la nouvelle
administration byden les chinois qui
sont laissons d'abord très pragmatiques
ils ont déjà pris une décision qui est
d'envoyer un représentant de
dassier haut niveau à washington après
l'installation de l'administration
maiden il s'agit de monsieur yang liwei
qui est le chargé des relations
extérieures au parti communiste chinois
est donc un personnage très important
pratiquement aussi important que le
ministre affaires étrangères de la chine
et qui va prendre la température à
washington pour voir quelles sont les
intentions américaines et sur quels
moyens
l'administration maiden va insister le
président au train on sait qu'il avait
horreur de tout ce qui était mis latéral
donc lui il avait choisi une voie
bilatérale
le rapport de force le bras de fer
bilatérales pure et simple
là ça va être un petit peu plus
compliqué un petit peu plus difficile
parce qu'on sait que les démocrates en
général et les jeunes en particulier
sont assez sensibles aux problèmes des
droits de l'homme donc qu'ils évoqueront
peut-être les questions taboues de la
répression à hong kong de la répression
des ouigours réduit également les
questions taïwanaise est pas question
bien entendu de reconnaître taïwan mais
on peut toujours augmenter le niveau de
relations informelles ou augmenter les
échanges de produits sensibles avec
taïwan
c'est cela que l'envoyé chinois de bras
évalué il dira en effet que la sphère de
taiwan est de loin la plus sensible que
les la chine est prête à négocier sur
les échanges commerciaux qu'elle est
peut-être prête à faire des efforts sur
la propriété industrielle sur les
investissements sur les subventions des
entreprises publiques mais que tout cela
doit se négocier dans un cadre
diplomatique normale
et puis je m'en rappelle aussi à
l'administration maiden quelles sont ses
intentions par rapport aux trans pacific
partnership
c'est ce traité qui avait été négocié
pendant assez longtemps entre 2008 et
et d'entrain paix sorti à grand bruit
quelques jours après sa prise de
fonctions en janvier 2017
et ce traité qui réunit en ce pays plus
est des états unis qui réunissait on
speed plus les états unis fonctionne
entre les onze pays à petit feu mais
effectivement n'a plus grand sens sans
les états unis
les chinois ont d'ailleurs en ont
profité pendant ce temps là pour
embrigader dans un autre traité tout
pratiquement tous les pays asiatiques
c'est un traité de coopération
commerciale donc ces questions seront
discutées et il est probable que mme
hayden aura a fixé la ligne de la
négociation future avec les chinois joe
biden qui a parlé d'une grande alliance
démocratique qu'est ce que cela veut
dire
eh bien ça peut vouloir dire bien sûr
beaucoup de choses
il a à plusieurs reprises parlé d'un
sommet des pays démocratiques et je
crois qu'il y tient beaucoup
il aura peut-être un petit peu de mal du
côté des pays asiatiques puisque en
effet d allié aussi proche des états
unis que le japon la corée du sud
l'australie et la nouvelle-zélande ont
signé il ya trois mois le traité dont je
parlais à l'instant qui est un traité
d'initiative si noir a traité de
libre-échange et de coopération signé et
de coopération économiques initiées par
les chinois donc les chinois ne se
prêteront pelez les quatre pays que je
viens de citer ne se prêteront pas
d'alliance anti chinoises pour l'europe
ça risque d'être un peu la même chose
puisque l'europe vient de signer un
traité sur les investissements avec la
chine et par conséquent considère qu' il
vaut mieux négocier discuter engagé la
chine
plutôt que d'organiser une confrontation
sous forme d'une alliance anti chinoises
un pays resté un petit peu à l'écart de
tout ça c'est l'inde et effectivement il
est probable que monsieur byden
cherchera à engager en gros les l'inde
dans ce front antichinois après tout il
ya une rivalité entre les deux grands
voisins
le plus grand pays du monde par la
population mais je doute que le
gouvernement indien se laisse embarquer
dans une opération de ce genre car il
gère sa relation avec la chine de façon
extrêmement fine et il ne voudra pas
apparaître comme participant à une
alliance anti chinoises
donc il restera à monsieur trump
peut-être de faire un sommet dès que des
démocraties
pourquoi pas ce sera une sorte de
d'événements d'événements où se
retrouveront ce qu'ils auront été invité
d'ailleurs sur quels critères
c'est un petit peu compliqué puisque si
chacun se définit comme démocrate il
faudra bien que les états unis fassent
le tri mais surtout ce qui est important
c'est la proposition ont fait plusieurs
anciens secrétaires d'état américains ou
secrétaire au trésor des tilles pas tant
de faire un sommet pour relancer
l'économie
l'économie mondiale est à plat et on a
besoin d'un sommet peut-être le g20
anticipé pour relancer l'économie
mondiale est traitée aussi des
conséquences de la pandémie et bien sûr
pour relancer l'économie mondiale
on a aussi besoin de la chine merci
claude blanchemaison l'onu dénonce ce
soir les répercussions humanitaires et
politiques à dix jours de la fin de son
mandat de l'administration trump annoncé
qu'elle allait inscrire les rebelles
houthi du yémen sur sa liste noire des
groupes terroristes
une décision lourde de sens qui entrera
en vigueur la veille de l'entrée en
fonctions du président élu joe biden
grazailles avec marc aussi c'est un
cadeau de départ en poids zone et que
l'administration trump laisse au yémen
une sanction à objectif or selon mike
pompéo les désignations vise à tenir en
sarre à la responsable de ses actes
terroristes y compris les attaques
transfrontalières menaçant les
populations civiles les infrastructures
et la navigation commerciale
elle vise également à faire progresser
les efforts pour parvenir à un yémen
pacifique souverain et uni à la fois
exempt d'ingérence iraniennes et en paix
avec ses voisins
trois dirigeants du groupe rebelle sont
également désormais inscrits sur cette
liste
une décision fermement condamné par les
responsables outils les américains sont
à l'origine du terrorisme
la politique et les actions de
l'administration trump sont du
terrorisme aussi ses politiques
reflètent une pensée en crise et sont
condamnables et nous avons le droit d'y
riposter
le groupe rebelles contrôlent
actuellement le nord ouest du yémen et
sa capitale sanaa l'iran grand ennemi de
washington lui sert d'appui politique
majeure de son côté le royaume saoudien
à la tête une coalition militaire
soutient le gouvernement yéménite face
aux outils cette sanction des états unis
est vaine selon téhéran après de
nombreuses années de bombardements du
yémen ils ont aujourd'hui atteint un
point où ils doivent cacher leur
incapacité derrière de telles actions
qui sont voués à l'échec
nan mais quand l'amour va dire la radio
ce qu'est le temps est maintenant loin
où ils devront venir négocier avec des
groupes responsables et complètement
nationaux dans différents pays y compris
le yémen ces actions n'ont aucune valeur
sérieuse dans les derniers jours du
régime américain à la maison blanche
pour de nombreuses organisations donald
trump cherche à frapper un grand coup
diplomatique contre l'iran avant
l'arrivée à la maison blanche de joe
biden qui a affirmé vouloir renouer le
dialogue avec la république islamique
des sanctions américaines qui entreront
en vigueur le 19 janvier la veille de la
prise de fonction du nouveau président
le gouvernement américain doit s'assurer
que les sanctions n'empêche pas l'entrée
de nourriture de carburant et de
médicaments dans un pays déjà en pleine
catastrophe humanitaire totale une
décision qui risque selon les
organisations internationales d'aggraver
la crise humanitaire en cours depuis
2014 début du conflit au yémen
une crise qui a déjà fait des dizaines
de milliers de morts restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la propagation du cobp ide en europe
et en france le variant anglais
inquiète alors que plusieurs cas ont été
détectés à marseille et à lille
et puis nous parlerons de séparatisme le
garde des sceaux eric dupond moretti
était auditionné par la commission
spéciale des députés chargée de l'examen
du projet de loi
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est des
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé
brunel sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ce
qu'il est guéri majoritaire mâcon et
passera sur d'autres acteurs avec nos
campagnes il faut savoir c'est qu'une
vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle en 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée de la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
ça aurait infecté au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inédit tg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent saison
qu'il avait envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario au réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être qu est-ce
qui va rester c'est que les films qui
seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques godard
qui disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma enlève
les yeux tout est dit
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 11 janvier a dit militer
collective en 2021 malgré les vaccins
déclarations pessimistes ce soir de l'
oms le coronavirus a fait dans le monde
plus de 1,9 million de morts l'équipe
d'experts de l'oms chargé d'enquêter sur
l'origine de la pandémie entamera sa
mission ce joli en chine c'est la
propagation rapide de nouveaux variants
plus contagieux qui inquiète et
entraînent une flambée des cas comme au
royaume uni et en allemagne
pour le moment on les chiffres à date
nous laisse penser que le couvre-feu
suffit précise le premier ministre mais
ajoute un troisième confinement n'est
pas à exclure en dernier recours la
france qui marche sur un fil et scrute
l'évolution l'épidémie alors que la
menace du variant britannique se fait de
plus en plus forte avec au moins huit
cas marseille et deux cas à lille plus
de cinquante mille doses du vaccin
moderna ont été livrés aujourd'hui afin
d'être utilisé dans la semaine aux
etats-unis cette double tentative des
représentants démocrates pour évincer
donald trump dont une mise en accusation
qui ouvrirait la voie à une nouvelle
procédure de destitution
il accuse d'avoir incité à la violence
au capitole twitter de son côté n'est
pas attendu pour faire taire le
président sortant son compte personnel a
été fermée définitivement alors
oligarchie numérique contre liberté
d'expression at on raison de bâillonner
le président des états unis
n est ce pas contre productif ce sera
l'objet de notre décryptage
le haut karabagh le sommet tripartite a
pris fin tout à l'heure le président
russe vladimir poutine accueilli son
homologue azéri et le premier ministre
de l'arménie au coeur des discussions
l'accord de cessation des hostilités
dans cette région du sud aucun signe et
il y a deux mois sous l'égide du kremlin
au programme également le volet
économique avec le développement des
relations commerciales et l'aide
humanitaire
[Musique]
outre-manche l'épidémie est hors de
contrôle avec le nouveau variant downing
street va lancer cette semaine une
campagne de dépistage massive
le royaume uni a dépassé la barre des 80
mille morts dus qu'aux vite ce week-end
robin pu elle la situation reste
critique au royaume uni le pays fait
actuellement face à une augmentation des
contaminations attribué à un variant
plus contagieux une accélération de plus
en plus difficile à contrôler et à
londres
l'état d'urgence dans les hôpitaux a
même été déclaré vendredi dernier depuis
une semaine le gouvernement de boris
johnson a renforcé les restrictions
sanitaires
mais la responsabilité du premier
ministre est pointé du doigt par
l'opposition je pense que la grande
majorité du public s'est conformé aux
règles
ils ont travaillé très dur et ça a été
un vrai combat le problème ce sont les
messages contradictoires du gouvernement
manger au restaurant ne sortait pas
manger aller au travail ne retournez pas
au travail restait à la maison ne restez
pas à la maison
le message central est désormais d'une
importance cruciale restez à la maison
sauver des vies et protéger notre
système de santé
l'annoncé d'un troisième confinement a
du mal à passer outre manche
samedi plusieurs dizaines de personnes
se sont rassemblées à londres pour
protester contre le durcissement des
restrictions sanitaires
une manifestation dans un contexte tendu
qui s'est soldé par plusieurs
arrestations même conscient de la
situation sanitaire
les britanniques ont du mal à respecter
ces nouvelles restrictions en regardant
le parc je pense que les gens sont
fatigués d'être isolé ils en ont marre
d'être confiné entre quatre murs c'est
terrifiant
je pense que nous avons en quelque sorte
atteint un point où tout le monde doit
prendre le virus beaucoup plus au
sérieux
mais ce troisième confinement est tout
simplement horrible et je pense que tout
le monde en a assez
nous voulons juste être prêt à trouver
une solution et attendre la fin pour
sortir de cette crise boris johnson mise
sur une vaccination à grande échelle qui
a commencé bien plus tôt que dans le
reste de l'europe
plusieurs vaccinodromes ont ouvert leurs
portes à travers tout le pays
le gouvernement espère avoir vacciné les
plus vulnérables et les soignants avant
la mi-février et le reste de la
population adulte d'ici à l'automne
situation tendue également en espagne
après les fêtes de fin d'année le nom de
contamination repart à la hausse ont
fait le point avec notre correspondante
et signe là une augmentation
considérable du nombre de cases ce sont
les mots employés par le gouvernement
espagnol
435 à de kovy de 19 pour cent mille
habitants dans les hôpitaux le taux
d'occupation en soin intensif de
patients attendu coronavirus est passé à
26 %
alors le gouvernement explique qu'il
s'attendait à de tels chiffres
après les déplacements et rassemblement
des espagnols durant les fêtes de fin
d'année il a tenu à expliquer que la
hausse n'est pas dû aux variants
britannique a paru dans le pays fin
décembre alors la situation n'est pas
encourageante les prochaines semaines
vont être compliqués les hôpitaux seront
sous pression et l'objectif est d'éviter
leur saturation
alors le gouvernement demande à ses
habitants de faire très attention de
fournir un effort supplémentaire et
malgré tout l'espagne écarte la
possibilité d'un nouveau confinement
je vous propose d'écouter fernando
simone du ministère de la santé
je t'invite ascione nous sommes dans une
situation très en-deça de la première
vague est très similaire à ce qu'il
s'est passé lors de la seconde vague
durant la deuxième vague
nous n'avons pas eu besoin de faire un
confinement et nous avons réussi à
contrôler et à avoir un impact moins
important sur la société et l'économie
je pense que si nous sommes dans une
situation où si nous sommes tous
conscients de ce que nous devons faire
et si nous le faisons que nous sommes
vraiment solidaires les uns les autres
et que les institutions font aussi ce
qu'elles doivent faire
je pense que nous pourrons ouvrir je
pense que nous pourrons réussir à
contrôler l'épidémie sont nécessité d'un
nouveau confinement
les experts prévoient la fin du tunnel
pour le début de l'été et en attendant
l'espagne active sa vaccination 50% des
doses reçues ont été administrés et le
pays compte accélérer la cadence pour
les prochaines semaines même qui se
prépare aussi à des semaines difficiles
et qui voit le nombre de cas augmente et
plus de précision avec peter oliver
correspondant d'arte et à berlin
le nombre de contaminations et de décès
liés à la co
19 est toujours élevé en allemagne au
cours des dernières 24 heures presque
seize mille personnes ont confirmé avoir
le coronavirus avec 425 décès
enregistrés dimanche soir ce sont des
chiffres particulièrement élevé pour un
week-end vendredi le triste record du
nombre de décès a été dépassé en
allemagne avec 1188 décès confirmés
merkel a tenu un discours solennel ce
week end incitant les allemands à
réfléchir à leur action et à leurs
conséquences pour leurs concitoyens les
mesures de confinement introduite avant
la période de fin d'année ont été
prolongées et renforcer la semaine
dernière quick resteront en place
jusqu'à la fin janvier et seront
réévaluées le 25
cependant il est probable qu'elles
seront encore prolongée des bars et
restaurants ne peuvent plus accueillir
de clients
les commerces de détail non essentiels
sont fermés ainsi que les coiffeurs les
écoles et les maternelles également été
mise en place pour les passagers
arrivant d'irlande suite à la flambée de
la mutation du coronavirus au royaume
uni des vols provenant du royaume uni
étaient déjà soumis à des restrictions
avant noël il semble qu'elles seront
étendues aux vols en provenance de
l'irlande également kovacs s'agissant du
vaccin angela merkel a promis
d'accélérer le programme de vaccination
d'autres nations européennes a été
critiqué pour la lenteur de déploiement
du vaccin et vientiane ministre de la
santé a déclaré à berlin qu'il était
satisfait du rythme de la vaccination
qu'ils savez prioriser les résidents des
centres de soins avant douvres
le programme à l'ensemble de la
population selon un porte-parole du
gouvernement anglais la merkel s'est
entretenue avec le président russe
vladimir poutine à propos d'une
éventuelle production du vaccin l'uss
stout nick v en allemagne le vaccin
devrait d'abord être validée par l'
agence européenne du médicament ceux qui
luttent pas encore le cas viet potes
mais le cas échéant le vaccin pourrait
bien être produits en allemagne les
retours en france toujours sur le front
du coc bits c'est une semaine décisive
qui s'annonce avec deux points qui
seront particulièrement scrutées par le
gouvernement les éventuelles
conséquences de réveillon du nouvel an
et celle du variant angles est détectée
sur le territoire en attendant les
réunions s'enchaînent avec la question
épineuse d'un troisième confinement pour
le moment exclue les explications de
neige abderrazek il ne faut pas exclure
un troisième confinement dernier recours
les propos sont signés du premier
ministre alors que nos voisins
britanniques et allemands ont déjà
confiné depuis plusieurs semaines jean
castex à envisager d'y avoir recours
pour l'hexagone
une troisième fois ce matin lors d'une
réunion avec les parlementaires et la
mise en oeuvre ne pourrait être qu'une
question de temps on parle également
d'une éventuelle mise en place d'un
couvre-feu à 18h étendue à tout le
territoire et pour cause les chiffres
liés aux kabyles 19 continue d'alarmé le
nombre de cas de contamination quotidien
tourne autour de 20 milles ces derniers
jours situation d'autant plus
inquiétante que le variant britannique a
été détectée sur le territoire français
à bagneux lille marseille invariants
dont on dit qu'il est plus contagieux
sous le feu des critiques après un début
de campagne de vaccination timide
emmanuel macron a piloté ce lundi après
midi une réunion de crise consacrée à la
stratégie de vaccination le chef de
l'état il était accompagné des
principaux un ministre
concernés d'ailleurs il faut savoir que
les premières doses du vaccin moderna
doivent être livrés à partir de ce lundi
pour renforcer la capacité vaccinale
dans les zones les plus touchées par
l'épidémie
mercredi un nouveau conseil de défense
est prévue à l'elysée juste avant le
conseil des ministres
et parmi les sujets à l'ordre du jour il
sera probablement question de mesures
plus restrictives pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus
les conséquences des mouvements des
fêtes de fin d'année devraient aussi
être connu et puis seront sûrement
aborder les inquiétudes liées aux
variantes anglaise et sud africaines du
virus inquiétudes qui pourrait donc être
précipitée des décisions sur des mesures
ou encore plus restrictive troisième
confinement couvre feu dès 18h étendues
à tout le pays ce sera donc à jean
castex et à olivier véran d'annoncer à
d'éventuelles nouvelles mesures le
lendemain jeudi pour la traditionnelle
conférence de presse hebdomadaire et
peut-être même une prise de parole du
président de la république
emmanuel macron une semaine qui
s'annonce donc chargée est crucial pour
le gouvernement et pour en parler nous
sommes avec vincent maréchal virologues
professeur de virologie à sorbonne
universités bonsoir vincent mahé sa
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on dit la france donc sur un
plateau mais on sent comme l'a dit notre
reporter que la semaine va être crucial
etc la situation pourrait évoluer et pas
forcément dans le bon sens on a dit
c'est ici un précurseur il ya des ce
qu'on appelle des signaux faibles la
remontée de décompte des quantités de
virus dans les eaux usées en sont
probablement d'autres indicateurs je
vous le confirme et bientôt on voit que
le nombre d'opca quotidien commence
doucement à augmenter on est dans une
situation difficile d'autant que la
période se cette période hivernale est
très très favorable à la circulation
des virus et en particulier du sart skov
2 donc non il ya un point de vigilance
important à mon sens ce qui est
important c'est d'agir vite et donc
c'est un peu le débat qu'on a
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut pas déjà se
fier des indicateurs fiables pour
prendre des mesures qui sont des mesures
efficaces
alors pour vous les mesures efficaces
elle est sur toutes les lèvres vous
pensez or confinement ou pas forcément
on n'est pas forcément obligé d'aller
jusque là en tout cas au niveau national
national la mesure efficace alors j'ai
peut-être vous surprendre c'est déjà de
responsabiliser encore une fois chacun
de chacun d'entre nous l'exécutif peut
pas être tenu seul garant des bonnes
mesures et des mesures à prendre qu'il
faut vraiment faire attention continuer
à respecter ces gestes barrière si le
virus circule c'est qu'il ya des niches
qui sont favorables à la circulation du
virus c'est qu'il ya des instants notre
vie encore où nous rencontrons des gens
qui qui contamine parce que nous ne
portons pas le masque donc à une
vigilance accrue à avoir et puis nous
payons va sans doute le en apercevoir
les les fêtes de fin d'année
on a pris plaisir à se retrouver mais
sans doute sans respecter totalement ses
règles et les remonter et que l'on voit
aujourd'hui sont probablement un écho
déjà précoce de ces de ses contacts un
peu trop fréquents et on en paie
aujourd'hui le tribut vous ne citez pas
le variant anglais qui pourtant est bel
et bien déjà sur notre territoire qui
serait deux fois plus contagieux d'un
virus qui l'étaient déjà avant c'est ça
le gros danger
aujourd'hui le danger c'est ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est principalement
quand même les formes classiques de
coronavirus vraisemblablement on est en
train de faire une analyse sur le
territoire on aura une idée plus précise
de la prévalence de ce variant
britannique je vous rappelle qu'à aussi
invariants qui vient d'afrique du sud
qui nous pose qui nous pose question
c'est pas c'est pas lui qui pose
problème mais si des gie ne sommes pas
en mesure de contrôler correctement la
circulation des virus classique
alors effectivement avec l'arrivée de ce
variant à très fort potentiel de
transmission
on est dans une situation critique il
faut prendre des décisions rapides
aujourd'hui vous dites décision rapide
ça veut dire quoi concrètement pense
aussi aux écoles qui restent
ça a été débattue maintes fois quel est
votre avis sur le sujet alors les écoles
les écoles sont pas forcément les
classes les écoles c'est un lieu où les
enfants parfois se rencontrent sans
masque et je pense notamment aux
cantines donc il serait important de
revérifier les protocoles sanitaires de
vérifier que les enfants ne passent pas
trop de temps vis-à-vis sans masque ça
c'est ce que je dirai pour l'instant sur
les écoles maintenant je pense également
que concernant le variant britannique il
est important de mettre en place des
mesures d'isolement isolement doit
redevenir la pratique classique et non
pas le test le test est là pour
confirmer des cas douteux ou des cas
présomptif de contamination mais l'
isolement et la barrière qui la barrière
efficace pour isoler les cas les cas les
plus importants donc on peut se poser la
question savoir si des gens qui viennent
de zones à risque où le virus circule
beaucoup notamment en grande-bretagne ne
devrait pas bénéficier d'office d'un
isolement dans la tente d'un test sous
quelques quelques jours qui serait un
test rassurante ou un test de
confirmation de l'isolant vous parlez du
variant sud-africain s'était
effectivement une de mes questions
tous ces variants vincent maréchal est
ce qu'on doit s'en inquiéter notamment
sur l'efficacité des différents vaccins
qui ont déjà été homologué ce qu'ils
vont l'être
alors il est un peu tôt pour le dire des
essais sont en cours
tous les vaccins qui sont en circulation
actuelle vise la protéine ce pack qui
est effectivement l'une des protéines
qui est altéré par ces mutations
néanmoins le lait il ya sur la protéine
spike différents sites sur lequel la
réponse immune va s'exercer et on pense
aujourd'hui mais il faudra le vérifier
que l'altération de quelques sites ne va
pas modifier de façon majeure la réponse
vaccinale toutefois tant que c'est pas
vérifiés en laboratoire
on restera en bout mais globalement les
échanges qu'on a laissé penser que les
vaccins restera efficaces contre ces
formes variantes
il faut préciser que plus vite on
bloquera la transmission ça c'est une
des questions qui se posent encore avec
le vaccin plus vite évidemment on
limitera la diffusion et l'apparition de
ces axes de ces deux scénarios
une bonne nouvelle tout de même
aujourd'hui un nouveau vaccin sur le
marché si j'ose dire avec l'arrivée de
modern art cinquante mille doses
c'est une nouvelle qui doit être bien
accueilli selon vous mais pas suffisante
on imagine alors c'est une c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce qu'on on a toujours
cette crainte de la rupture des stocks
c'est une bonne nouvelle également parce
que c'est un vaccin qui circulent à une
température un peu plus élevé que le
vaccin kaiser ce qui veut dire qu a
priori on aura moins de difficultés de
distribution en revanche les volumes
livrés nous ne sont des volumes
d'appoint on peut le dire aujourd'hui
ils vont nous aider à couvrir cette
première vague de vaccination toutefois
effectivement il faut s'assurer qu'on
puissent vacciner tout le monde et qu'on
puissent vacciner deux fois sur tout
dont on attend aussi beaucoup le vaccin
sera zeneca plus simple dans la
logistique
un vaccin qui devrait on l'espère
recevoir un agrément européen bientôt et
qui de qui beaucoup moins cher également
on en parle assez peu du prix des
vaccins
c'est pas parce qu'on ne les paye pas en
tant qu'utilisateur bénéficiaires qui
n'ont pas un coup ils ont un coût ces
vaccins l'axé astrazeneca coûte moins
cher quand même alors il faut modérer
l'enthousiasmé de ses vaccins parce que
évidemment c'est on en parle
régulièrement sur cette antenne il y a
beaucoup de sceptiques notamment en
france mais aussi cette déclaration ce
soir de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui nous dit que selon moi il n'y
aura pas d' immunité due aux vaccins en
tout cas en 2021 quelle est la réaction
du médecin vous être j'ai pas je suis
pas je suis pas médecin je suis
scientifique mais je peux avoir sont
quand même dans la alors j'ai pas vu la
déclaration de l'om est sous faire
attention à ce que à ce qu'on dit ce qui
est clair c'est que le déploiement du
vaccin qu'il soit juste préventif des
formes les plus graves ou qu'ils
bloquent la transmission du virus
ce déploiement vaccinale va prendre du
temps on le voit il va prendre au moins
six mois en france
certains pays n'ont pas commencé
certains pays n'ont pas encore organiser
la lutte et l'intégration des
calendriers vaccinaux donc je pense que
la remarque de la de louer baisse tend à
dire qu'effectivement à l'échelle
mondiale puisque c'est quand même
l'objectif de l'om et on ne sera pas en
mesure d'assurer une diffusion totale du
vaccin à l'échelle mondiale avant la fin
de l'année 2021
merci beaucoup vincent maréchal
virologues effectivement professeur de
virologie à la sorbonne universités
merci à vous d'avoir été sur notre
antenne
c'est l'une des lois très attendue du
quinquennat mais kron a le texte contre
les séparatismes religieux rebaptisé
projets de lois confortant les principes
républicains qui contient 54 articles
les deux ministres concernés ont été
auditionnés tout à l'heure par la
commission spéciale chargée de l'examen
du projet de loi le point à l'assemblée
nationale avec katia technique
les deux ministres ont détaillé les
articles qui relève de leur ministère
commençons par eric dupond moretti
il estime que le texte est essentiel
porteurs de liberté on écoute ce projet
pour moi comme pour le président de la
république
et comme pour le gouvernement bien sûr
est un texte essentiel
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire que
c'était un texte de liberté on ce que de
façon presque tautologique rappeler ce
que sont les valeurs de la république
c'est rappeler ce qu'est la liberté et
il est essentiel pour nous de nous
prémunir des dérives séparatistes d'où
qu'elles viennent d'ailleurs qui
menacent la nation et la république
essentiel de réaffirmer que tous les
français de kiel viennent quel que soit
le dieu qu'il prie ou qu'il ne prit pas
font avant tout partie d'une communauté
la communauté nationale est essentielle
enfin parce que ce texte a pour ambition
de renforcer les principes qui fondent
notre état de droit afin de lutter
efficacement contre eux
toutes les idéologies qui le menacent et
c'est parce que les enjeux de ce texte
sont si grands qu'une commission a été
spécialement constituée pour
l'appréhender je veux souligner ici
devant vous l'importance que revêt bien
sûr le débat parlementaire au regard de
l'objet de ce projet de loi parce qu'il
touche à ce qui fait le pacte
républicain
alors l'article 3 par exemple va
sanctionner les auteurs d' apologie du
terrorisme autre provocation en ligne ou
public et seront désormais
automatiquement inscrit au fijais le
fichier national judici
r d infractions à caractère terroriste
eric dupond moretti a également présenté
l'article 4 qui sanctionnera un nouveau
délit la menaces ou intimidations envers
un agent de service public pour qu'il
modifie sa mission de service public on
ne pense par exemple à un élève qui
menacerait un professeur pour qu'il
change le contenu de son cours ce
nouveau délit sera sanctionné de cinq
ans de prison ou 75000 euros d'amendé
quant à l'article 18 il crée un délit de
mise en danger intentionnelle de la vie
d'autrui en divulguant des informations
privées familiales ou professionnelles
sur internet
quant à marlène schiappa à ministre
délégué en charge de la citoyenneté
elle a évoqué un contrat républicain que
devra signer obligatoirement toute
association qui sollicite une subvention
ou un local c'est un contrat qui fait la
part belle à la laïcité ou à l'égalité
hommes femmes notamment
elle a détaillé une égalité de
traitement entre héritiers qui
permettrait une femme de ne pas être
désavantagés en cas d'héritage autres
articles portant sur le refus ou la loue
le non renouvellement du titre de séjour
en cas de polygamie ou encore
l'interdiction des certificat de
virginité
voilà ce qu'on peut retenir de
l'intervention des deux ministres
aujourd'hui pour en parler nous sommes
avec un hadji bazerghi fondateur de
l'union des démocrates musulmans
français bonsoir najib ouazzani merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
une première réaction à ces deux
auditions tout d'abord oui bonsoir et
merci pour votre invitation ce soir donc
c'est un sujet qui est effectivement
montre à quel point le gouvernement
aujourd'hui essaye absolument de faire
des effets d'annoncé par rapport au
bilan catastrophique que nous sommes
tous en train de de constater ces deux
dernières années c'est un bilan
catastrophique et dans lequel le
gouvernement tente un échappatoire en
essayant effectivement d'un calvaire
peut à ce qu'on appelle rêve l'ordre
républicain qui ne veut dire en réalité
pas grand chose et qui clairement n'est
pas quantifiable
l'indicateur qui lui par contre devrait
intéresser tout le monde c'est l'
indicateur sur le chômage sur la santé
sur sur l'égalité et une sur des choses
en tout cas qui sont beaucoup plus
cartésienne or là effectivement nous
avons un gouvernement qui nous pond une
nouvelle loi rallonge dans lequel
effectivement il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont dit de ci de là mais qui en
réalité sont beaucoup de défaites
annonce et qui en réalité ne sanctionne
enfin tout ce qui est tout ce qu il dit
qu'elle est quasiment aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'apologie du terrorisme par
rapport à la citation là elles sont déjà
des choses qui sont dans leur grande
mesure déjà appliquée est applicable
depuis depuis longtemps donc on sent
bien qu'aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement
qui est aux abois
parce que en termes de chômage c'est une
catastrophe en termes de sur la crise
sanitaire on est frappé de nouveau par
une deuxième vague et on voit bien que
enfin ça ça le gouvernement n'a rien mis
en place de dire l'un n'empeche
peut-être pas l'autre il y à des études
assez régulière dans une récemment qui
pointe le recul de la laïcité notamment
dans les établissements scolaires
ça ne correspond pas à la réalité selon
vous les études y en a beaucoup qui sont
faites dans une étude donc on peut lire
j'ai un peu tout et même son inverse
en réalité aujourd'hui on peut constater
alors j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses
j'ai entendu ces derniers temps que je
pense que vous l'avez également vous
remarqué j'ai entendu un ministre de
l'intérieur qui était choquée par les
rayons j'ai été aussi frappé de voir que
aujourd'hui on a dissout des
organisations des ong des collectifs qui
luttait contre la discrimination sous un
motif qui est effectivement celui de de
la lutte contre le terrorisme
la décapitation or ces fermetures n'ont
aucun rapport avec leurs chefs
d'accusation donc effectivement on dit
beaucoup de choses on entend beaucoup de
choses mais dans la réalité
effectivement sous pas vraiment de la
réalité de ce que vivent les français
on est à même loin de ce constat
effectivement extrêmement une dernière
question vous reprend le chemin à droite
vous le savez votre communautarisme
en tout cas le double micro parti que
vous êtes
est ce que vous avez eu votre mot vous
avez été associé aux discussions avec
les responsables musulmans sur ce projet
de loi
j'ai le sentiment plutôt que les
responsables musulmans sont aujourd'hui
traités par notamment par l'exécutif
un peu comme hôte encore une fois des
colonies c'est à dire qu'on essaye
effectivement de faire de l'ingérence au
lieu d'essayer de travailler avec
aujourd'hui les partenaires de la
communauté musulmane
les responsables d'autres cas vu du
culte musulman aujourd'hui on demande
effectivement une labellisation des
délégués dit mam entend donc beaucoup de
choses
et effectivement les accusations les
éléments de langage qui consiste à nous
qualifier le de communautariste parce
qu'elles le sont en réalité eux de façon
beaucoup plus manifeste je pense à une
certaine de droite dure voire avec des
médias au logis très proche de l'extrême
droite
je pense que voilà on est effectivement
des opposants politiques et à ce titre
là il va de soi que nous coller
plusieurs étiquettes en réalité vu des
mèches n'est pas un parti comme une tare
est telle que certains entendent où on
est justement le rempart contre le
séparatisme
nous sommes là pour méditer pour une
république qui puisque à respecter et
puis surtout à protéger et à chaque
citoyen est pratiquée et toutes les
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui la diff
diffamer discréditer en fonction de
leurs hommes de leur patronyme en
fonction de lourds de la croyance
avérées ou supposées
merci majimaji d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france dans quelques
instants rester avec nous n'en viendrons
sur twitter qui a décidé de fermer
définitivement le compte personnel de
donald trump oligarchie numérique contre
liberté d'expression at on raison de
bâillonner le président des états unis
n'est ce pas de contre productif
ce sera l'objet de notre décryptage en
quelques instants
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être que ce qui
va rester c'est que les films qui seront
de plus en plus fait pour le cinéma et
pas sur les grands réseaux resteront des
objets artistiques
sting godard qui disait cette chose si
forte quand on regarde la télévision en
baisse les yeux quand on va au cinéma on
lève les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
et
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes
le son il est là mon les actes et j'ai
trop de dépenses trop d'état je pense en
tout cas qu'il ya trop de bureaucratie
c'est à dire un état inefficace tout ça
a été financée essentiellement par de la
dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croatie donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france aux etats-unis cette double
tentative des représentants démocrates
pour évincer donald trump à neuf jours
de la passation de pouvoir la première
une résolution demandant au
vice-président en peines de démettre son
patron mais l'unanimité requise par le
25e amendement n'a pas été obtenue la
présidente de la chambre nancy pelosi a
d'ailleurs accusé des républicains qui
ont voté contre je signe de complicité
avec donald trump et de mettre en danger
l'amérique autres tentatives la mise en
accusation du président américain qui
ouvrirait la voie à une nouvelle
procédure de destitution un double vote
doit avoir lieu demain mais il est peu
probable que le mandat de trump souhaite
écourtée et twitter en tout cas n'a pas
attendu de son côté pour écourter la
durée de vie de son compte et faire
taire le président sortant son compte
personnel a été fermée définitivement
d'autres plateformes ont suspendu le
compte de locataire de la maison blanche
comme facebook instagram sweet youtube
ou snep tchad suscitant de nombreuses
réactions et posant la question de la
place qu'occupent les réseaux sociaux
dans la démocratie et le débat public
alors oligarchie numérique contre
liberté d'expression at on raison de
bâillonner le président des états unis
n'est ce pas contre productif place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs andré bercoff
journaliste auteur de donald trump les
raisons de la colère comment et pourquoi
il est devenu président chez first
editions à vos côtés didier combo
spécialiste des états unis merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
avant d'évoquer ce ce débat sur cette
censure hein peut-on appeler ça on va on
va d'ailleurs en débattre ensemble
est-ce qu'on peut prononcer le mot de
censure je voulais aborder avec vous une
information qui est tombée en fin de
journée cette résolution qui va passer
au vote et qui marquera l'ouverture
formelle de la destituer une tentative
en tout cas de destitution contre trump
à ce que ce n'est pas un petit peu trop
tard andré bercoff c'est un symbole en
tout cas moi écouter c'est exactement
les les démocrates en fait tu voudrais
que trump bien pour eux c'est pire que
ben laden salaire que ce qu'il souhaite
c'est qu'il soit un jour je tue et jetés
en mer et surtout qu'on ne qu'il
disparaisse qu'on n'entende plus parler
de lui
il y a quand même cette espèce de ça
fait quand même totalement aller je
dirais tragique en comics en fait ce
n'est pas envie de vraiment de deux de
rire avec avec cette espèce de il est à
huit jours de 2,2 de son départ
et au fait une procédure de destitution
alors soit disant pour l'empêcher de
revenir en 2024
il y a une espèce ou sauvés c'est à la
mesure cette frénésie est à la mesure de
la peur panique qui a eu pendant quatre
ans n'oubliez jamais que trappe et télé
sur pattes heures c'était quelqu'un qui
va surtout ne devais pas le président de
la république et ils ont les aurons il a
été président contre toute atteinte en
2016 et il fallait surtout pas que la
catastrophe je pars à rudy mais pour un
certain nombre de gens se renouvelle et
on a tout fait pour ça et là on sent
avec ce que vous avez dit sur les gars
phare avec nous on n'aime pas la censure
fin ça va beaucoup plus loin quoi avec
l'ordre règne à varsovie
on ne veut plus le voir une tête qui
passe et surtout pas celle de trump très
franchement
ce n'était pas aussi tragique pour ceux
qui montrent ce que montrent les
ats-unis le fossé ce serait assez
dérisoires 1 didier convard en parallèle
un anti pelosi a présenté un ultimatum à
malpensa dimanche activé en urgence le
25e amendement qui consiste à constater
l'inaptitude du président exercer sa
fonction un républicain s'est opposé
aujourd'hui à son adoption immédiate à
l'unanimité que cherche à faire les
démocrates puisque de toute façon donald
trump va s'en aller avec toutes les
critiques 1 qui entourent le président
sortant aujourd'hui donc quel est le but
finalement m'écouter étant donné ce qui
s'est passé au capitole bien entendu là
la classe politique doit doit réagir à
cela mais l'objectif des démocrates il
est double 1 comme le disait andré
bercoff ils ont comme objectif de rendre
trump inéligible rendu 2024
mais ils ont aussi un objectif
d'introduire un coin au sein du parti
républicain pour essayer de de séparer
les soutiens de troy des républicains
puis modéré qui commence à être un petit
peu embarrassé par trump en quelque
sorte et c'est certainement la raison
pour laquelle nancy pelosi a lancé un
ultimatum peines pour faire jouer le 25e
amendement ce qui serait
institutionnellement très difficile de
façon alors les démocrates mettent en
avant je cite un président déranger une
menace imminente contre la démocratie
américaine
trump pour l' aime ou on aime pas il l'a
tout de même un bilan parce que ça ils
s'assemblent être éludée aujourd'hui
andré bercoff vous l'expliquez comment
cette haine anti trump aujourd'hui il
s'est tiré une balle dans le pied lui
même le président sortant avec ces
images catastrophiques au capitole
écoutez l'image du libyen jusqu'à sainte
sophie du capitole certes mais enfin ça
n'a pas été la prise du palais d'hiver
ni la prise de la bastille
je crois que vraiment il faut il faut
relativiser tout ça je crois que tous
les moyens étaient bons pour se
débarrasser notre hub trump ne levait
pas son bilan quand même vois pas faire
tout son bilan enfin sur le chômage sur
le pouvoir d'achat et caetera et même
sur les vaccins il faut pas oublier que
si pfizer a pu faire ça c'est que trump
a injecté et même les les adversaires
les plus résolus trompeuses à injecter
des milliards de dollars fédéraux dans
le
et puis parlons pas de politique
étrangère parlons pas tout le reste
franchement que trump aujourd'hui il y a
eu cette histoire du capitole mais que
tout le reste disparaissent au profit de
voir à l'espèce de charlatans fou et
quand même une d'une dérision
fantastique et je rejoins un
interlocuteur en disant que
effectivement ce qui va se passer c'est
ça le plus grave c'est que les
démocrates ne voient pas qu'ils
introduisent avec ça une division
terrible en amérique je crois que
vraiment on va entendre beaucoup parler
dans les prochains mois
au delà évidemment de la personne de
trump de ses 75 millions d'américains
qu'ils osent empire gruger de cette
élection et les autres si vous voulez du
côté démocrate
vous allez avoir la gauche du parti
démocrate représenté par kamala harris
la vice présidente qui va jouer un rôle
très important donc on va véritablement
et on le voit déjà avec cette espèce
d'extra hors de la pression de toutes
les censures un pas seulement les gars
fin je vous signale quelque chose qui
vient de se passer il y avait des
partisans de trump vous savez après le
capitole qui sont restés de trois jours
à washington qui sont rentrés et bien
l'une des compagnies aériennes a refusé
de les prendre
parce qu'il est né vous est sur la liste
des terroristes
c'est à dire qu'il ya quelque chose de
complètement irrationnel là dedans et
vraiment il faudra faire très attention
toutefois pour l'amérique parce que ça
risque de donner des lendemains qui
déchantent très fort alors destitution
par les réseaux sociaux n'ont pas
attendu un pour clouer le bec au
président sortant ils ont pris la
décision seul a commencé par twitter
écouter après un examen at-on
des tweets récents du conte real donald
trump et le contexte qui les entoure
nous avons suspendu définitivement le
compte en raison du risque de nouvelles
incitations à la violence
didier combo est ce qu'ils ont eu raison
d'aller jusque là fermeture définitive
du comptant 80 mille abonnés on
l'appelle comme un million par blonde
abonnés on le rappelle c'est pas un
c'est pas contre-productif
ces six parce que le les
conspirationnistes qui soutiennent tron
10 prétendre prétendent apporter des
informations qui sont cachés par
l'establishment donc si on leur coupe
leurs moyens de communication ils
n'auront que plus raison de dire ça et
puis bien évidemment ça pose un problème
puisque trump puisque twitter est une
entreprise privée et c'est donc une
entreprise privée qui va censurer non
pas des propos d'ailleurs mais censuré
une personne puisque il ne s'agit pas
d'effacer telle ou telle fuite de tram
il s'agit de lui interdire l'accès à
twitter et ça à mon avis c'est
contreproductif il parle et puis d'autre
part ça pose le problème de savoir si
une entreprise privée est légitime à
faire cette chose là et de surcroît il
ne faut pas oublier que les manades la
silicon valley sont des soutiens de
démocrates donc c'est d'autant plus
gênant kill kill kill un qui ne ferment
ce conte de tron
c'est d'autant plus sujet à critique
alors via twitter n'est pas le seul à
annoncer la suspension par 90 du comte
de donald trump
regardez c'est impressionnant le nom de
plateformes qui ont béni le président
sortant pertinentes ou non la décision
de censurer le président en exercice
peut-elle être décidée par une
entreprise sans contrôle légitime et
démocratique
la suspension du compte de trump la
purge des géants du numérique contre ses
partisans devrait indigner tout citoyen
attaché à la démocratie
où s'arrêtera ce contrôle de toutes
opinions dissidentes
qui demain sera effacée numériquement
sans possibilité de se défendre
trump c'est pas ma tasse de thé mais la
fermeture désormais définitif de son
compte par twitter me paraît scandaleuse
doit-on délégué notre liberté
d'expression au géant de la silicon
valley demain ce sera pour nous tous
cette censure numérique et privés la
fermeture du compte de donald trump par
twitter si elle peut se justifier par
une forme de prophylaxie d'urgence n'en
pose pas moins des questions
fondamentales la régulation du débat
public par les principaux réseaux
sociaux au regard de leurs seules
conditions générales d'utilisation
alors qu'ils sont devenus de véritables
espaces publics et rassemble des
milliards de citoyens
cela semble pour le moins un peu court
d'un point de vue démocratique au delà
de la haine en ligne nous avons besoin
d'inventer une nouvelle forme de
supervision démocratique
le comportement de trump ne peut servir
de prétexte pour que les gaffes à
s'arroge le pouvoir de contrôler le
débat public
les lois macro ont pourtant légalisé
cette censure privé alors là on vient de
voir effectivement les réactions
politiques nombreuses aujourd'hui après
ce bannissement de donald trump des
réseaux sociaux je vous parlais des
plates formes à on les voit enfin
apparaître un an restera ou bannis le
président de trump on le voit on ne
s'attendait pas forcément entendre
quelqu'un comme jean luc mélenchon
défendre donald trump et pourtant
jusqu'à une gueule à merkel qui a trouvé
que cela posé problème
vous comprenez didier combo qu'en france
finalement on s'étonne de cette forme si
j'ose dire de censure
oui tout à fait et communiquer ce qui
est ce qui est étonnant ce qui peut être
rassurant d'une certaine manière c'est
que cette indignation
on la voit sur tout le spectre politique
donc il y a effectivement un problème
c'est un problème qui est extrêmement
difficile à résoudre parce que c'est
plate forme ne sont pas des éditeurs ne
sont pas les journaux un journal peut
choisir de publier ou ne pas publier
telle personne mais ces réseaux sociaux
c'est l'équivalent des fabricants de
papier en quelque sorte c'est le mois
et ils n'ont pas de responsabilité
éditoriale d'un genre byers en cause un
problème parce que les ils ne sont pas
considérés comme des des médias
ordinaire aux etats unis ils ne peuvent
pas être tenus pour responsables de ce
qu'il ait posté sur leur plateforme
mais d'un autre côté si ils censurent
quelqu'un alors à ce moment-là ils
agissent comme des journaux et comme des
éditeurs est donc là il a ici une
tension entre entre ces deux points et
qui est en train de faire débat aux
états unis andré bercoff ce sont
clairement les gaffes à aujourd'hui qui
décide qui peut qui doit prendre la
parole au nom
écoutez ça va beaucoup plus loin moi je
vais vous dire quelque chose je pense
que pinochet est aujourd'hui à la
silicon valley faut le dire
saastal si on ne fait pas attention une
véritable dictature de la parole une
dictature qui va peser au delà de
l'histoire de trump on ne peut pas
laisser parce que ce n'est pas un
problème américain
c'est un problème français c'est un
problème mondial ça problème évidemment
européen
on ne peut pas laisser des gens ddd
quelques multimilliardaire ils sont cinq
multimilliardaire régenter la planète et
régenter la liberté d'expression le
phénomène dont les points est très grave
c'est beaucoup plus grave que ce qui
s'est passé au capitole ou ailleurs
c'est i ils ont profité de quelque chose
l'incendié du reichstag je veux pas
faire toutes comparaisons historiques
ce serait malvenu mais je veux dire
qu'il y a quelque chose de grave
aujourd'hui dans le fait que quelque
personne je dis bien quelques personnes
parce qu'on les a laissés devenir des
monopoles les légats femmes peuvent
régenter véritablement les paroles de
tout le monde
je crois que pour moi c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très grave
et justement quand on parle de fascisme
sont désolants de qui et de quoi on
parle
merci en tout cas à tous les deux andré
bercoff didier combo d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france
enfin à l'instant du sommet tripartite
est moscou au sujet du haut karabagh le
président russe vladimir poutine
accueille son homologue azéri et le
premier ministre de l'arménie au coeur
des discussions l'accord de cessation
des hostilités dans cette région du sud
caucase signé il y a deux mois sous
l'égide du kremlin
au programme également le volet
économique avec le développement des
relations internationales et l'aide
humanitaire à des thèmes seront abordés
hier soir vladmir poutine et emmanuel
macron lors d'un entretien téléphonique
la correspondance à monstres ou
d'antoine claireaux d'aubry les trois
hommes se sont présentés face à la
presse après près de quatre heures de
pourparlers
vladimir poutine dans sa prise de parole
annoncé la signature d'un document
paraphé par les trois dirigeants sur le
développement sur l'évolution de la
situation dans le haut karabakh
je considère que la réunion
d'aujourd'hui est exceptionnellement
importante et utile car nous avons pu
élaborer et signé une déclaration
commune sur l'évolution de la situation
dans la région avec des démarches
concrètes pour la création de liens
économiques et le développement de
projets d'infrastructures à ses fins un
groupe de travail qui sera dirigé par
les vice premiers ministres des trois
gouvernements sera créé et azerbaïdjan
arménie et russie ils créeront des sous
groupes d'experts dans un avenir proche
et présenteront des plans spécifiques
pour le développement des
infrastructures de transport et
économiques de la région
je suis convaincu que la mise en oeuvre
de ces accords sera bénéfique au peuple
arménien et azerbaïdjanais et qu'elle
sera sans aucun doute utile à toute la
région
le président azerbaïdjanais estime que
l'application de cet accord permettra de
répondre de façon efficace à l'épineuse
question des axes de communication qui
desservent ce territoire enclavé
premier ministre arménien mis sous
pression par une partie de la population
dans son propre pays s'est montré un peu
moins enthousiaste il a pointé du doigt
la question humanitaire qui à ses yeux
n'est pas réglée et en particulier le
sort des prisonniers de guerre
malheureusement aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas réussi à résoudre la question des
prisonniers de guerre et c'est le point
le plus sensible dans la question dans
cette question humanitaire et nous
allons donc poursuivre comme nous sommes
comme nous sommes convenus nous allons
poursuivre nos efforts dans cette
direction et nous considérons en
particulier que le huitième point de
notre déclaration commune n'est pas mise
en oeuvre complètement et j'espère que
nous parviendrons très prochainement à
une solution concrète pour terminer
vladimir poutine a de nouveau remercié
les deux dirigeants d'avoir fait le
déplacement et s'est félicité de la
signature de cet accord bien entendu
mais aussi du respect du cessez-le-feu
depuis maintenant un peu plus de deux
mois le président russe mise donc sur le
développement des projets
d'infrastructures et le renforcement des
liens économiques afin de faire revenir
la paix dans cette région du caucase et
pour en parler nous sommes avec jean de
gliniasty directeur de recherche à
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques bonsoir merci
direct sur rt france la signature d'une
déclaration commune ce jour une nouvelle
étape pour vous pour entériner un peu
plus le cessez le feu
je crois en effet que à partir du moment
où la russie a été un acteur principal
dans la médiation dans la signature de
l'accord la russie se devait de de
continuer ses efforts pour apaiser
complètement la région et ceci passe
évidemment par des accords de
développement économique de
développement des infrastructures la
construction de la route entre
stepanakert et et javan une deuxième
route qui double le corridor de latchine
probablement aussi la question de la
communication entre le nakhitchevan et
l'azerbaïdjan est donc un vrai programme
de développement auquel sans doute
d'ailleurs la communauté internationale
sera invité à participer mais il ya sans
doute d'autres choses qui n'apparaissent
pas dans la déclaration commune qui ont
été discutés qui sont évidemment très
importante le d'abord la question du
statut du haut karabakh puisque chacun
sait que l'accord du 10 novembre ne
comporte aucune disposition sur ce
statut est sans aucun doute les trois on
en parlait et notamment la question des
garanties à donner aux populations
arméniennes la question des lieux saints
arméniens des monastères tout ça tout
cela sans doute était était abordé bien
sûr et il ya peut-être encore une
question qui a été traité mais qui ne
figurera pas dans les communiqués qui a
été traité m voce c'est la question de
la turquie puisque chacun sait aussi que
les turcs ne figure pas dans l'accord du
10 novembre qui sont très demandeurs
d'être présent sur le terrain que les
discussions sont allées bon train sur
cette question que les turcs ont obtenu
de participer à la station de contrôle
radio électronique qui sera installée en
territoire
l'azerbaïdjanais et qu'ils ont tenu
aussi de participer à l'effort de
déminage des zones récupéré par les arcs
d'azerbaïdjan est donc en dehors de la
déclaration qui elle même est centré
plus sur les questions de développement
il y as d'autres questions qui ont sans
doute été traité et nous ne connaissons
pas les résultats
alors notamment peut-être la question
majeure et non des moindres à deux
statues du nagorny karabach qui pourrait
intervenir qu'en cette question une
situation qui ne saurait être abordé
trop tôt et bien en fait pour les
azerbaïdjanais n'y a pas de question
c'est à dire que pour eux le le nagorny
karabakh faisant partie du territoire
azerbaïdjanais
il ne relève pas d'un statut particulier
qui serait à gré au niveau international
et a créé avec l'arménie mais ça c'est
au niveau déclaratoire defacto je pense
que le médiateur russe s'efforcera
d'obtenir un minimum de garanties pour
les populations arméniennes la
population arménienne justement qui
craint de son côté de nouvelles
concessions de nikol pashinian mais il y
aura forcément selon vous je crois que
la corse suffit à lui-même
dans cet accord il y à l'essentiel début
de guerre de l'azerbaïdjan c'est la
récupération du territoire
azerbaïdjanais et l'absence de vin et la
récupération d'une liberté de manoeuvre
total sur le le statut à supposer qu'il
y ait un statut en tout cas aussi il a
accordé aux citoyens aux citoyens donc
désormais azerbaïdjanais du nagorny
karabakh mais qui sont arméniens en fait
quid de l'aide humanitaire c'est
également l'un des sujets
qui devait être abordée est extrêmement
important ce sera ma dernière question
l'aide humanitaire c'est un c'est
toujours une des questions est à dire
les moins difficiles à régler comme vous
le savez par exemple la france a envoyé
avec l'accord des autorités russes des
avions cargos pour soulager les
populations arméniennes
la question se pose en termes de dead à
la réinstallation éventuellement des
azerbaïdjanais mais ça ce sera plutôt
une question azerbaïdjanaise et turque
et en ce qui concerne le le haut
karabagh la reconstruction dépendra en
fait de des désaccords qui sont fur et à
mesure signée mais l'aide humanitaire ne
devrait pas poser de problèmes
importants dans l'art et dans la région
enfin chacun aidant les siens si je puis
dire merci beaucoup aux gens de
gliniasty est directeur de recherche à
l'institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques d'avoir été avec nous et
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est bon